[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHMIDT: It is a pleasure
to welcome you back, Dr.
Kissinger, to Google.
You were here a few
years ago to a
sellout crowd of Googlers.
Dr. Kissinger is back, having
already met with some of the
key members of our search
and legal team.
And he's come for his demo of
Google Glass and a few other
things like that.
For those of you who don't
know why Dr. Kissinger
matters, it's worth
understanding the life that he
has led and the impact
that he has had.
For those of you that have not
followed it, this is the man
who, in many ways, made
globalization
happen in the world.
This is the man who settled
the war that
would have killed me.
This is the man who drove
American foreign policy not
just in one presidency, but I
would say for decades in terms
of an impact and role.
It'd be fair to say that it's
great to see someone of your
intellect, educated, professor
at Harvard, in politics and
governance.
Because he understands the
consequences of what he did
and the impact he had.
But more importantly, he
understands it with the
historic context.
So welcome to Google,
Dr. Kissinger.
HENRY KISSINGER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HENRY KISSINGER: Eric is leaving
me in the position I
was in at a reception once,
where a lady came up to me and
said, I understand you are
a fascinating man.
She said, fascinate me.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: It was not one
of the best conversations
I ever had.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: But
I appreciate what
have you have said.
And I'm a great admirer of what
Google is doing, even
though I have thought about the
long-term impact, as we
have discussed.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So what I thought
we would do is, we
have some Dory questions that
you all have submitted.
But I thought I'd use the
privilege of the moderator to
ask some questions about what's
going on in the globe
today, with the benefit of
your perspective and
experience.
And let's start with some
hard current problems.
Let's start with Iran, Syria,
the Middle East.
You actually drove the peace
process 40 years ago.
You actually made peace in the
Middle East 40 years ago.
Not much has happened since, and
a lot of bad things have
happened since--
nuclear bomb possibility in
Tehran, the Syrian civil war,
which is horrific.
From your perspective,
two questions--
what do you think will happen,
just using your judgment, and
also, what should America do,
if anything, about each of
these issues?
HENRY KISSINGER: In the
next 10 minutes?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
Google, right?
Things are done quickly.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: I come
from a generation that
learned from books.
I approach foreign policy as a
history, in the sense that I
ask myself what comparable
situations have existed.
And I was in office in a period
of domestic discord
even more intense,
in some respects,
than the current one.
Because it was when the America
lost its innocence in
foreign policy and began
to learn its limits.
So let me talk about the
peace process in the
Middle East at the time.
When I got into office,
it had been
stalemated for a long period.
And the attempt was to break
the deadlock with making
proposals on the theory that
somewhere out there there was
some formula that would
permit the parties--
we made a different analysis.
And in the way I think of
foreign policy, which I'm not
insisting everybody has to,
you have to start with
analyzing the problem.
What is the issue you
are trying to solve?
And what is it you're
trying to get to?
So we made what you
may consider a
simple-minded analysis.
We said, the Soviet Union is
supplying arms to all of the
Arab countries, and we're trying
to make peace between
Israel and the Arab countries.
And The Arab countries have
no incentive to make any
concessions because they believe
that the Soviet arms
will always give them
the possibility to
insist on their demands.
And the Israelis won't make
concessions because they think
it's just the prelude
to a showdown.
Some of that exists today
in a different form.
So we decided that be would
block any initiative that was
backed by Soviet arms.
And we had to fight our own
bureaucracy, which wanted to
do the traditional thing.
So we were waiting.
We were betting on the fact that
some Arab leader along
the way would change.
And it was a long wait.
It took about four years.
But when the Arab-Israeli board
started in '73, we sent
a message to Sadat, and said to
him, you're now making war
with Soviet arms.
But remember, you have to make
peace with American diplomacy.
So then he switched
and began to work
with American diplomacy.
That was the essence.
We don't have a comparable
situation today.
Because if you take Iran, we
know that the acquisition of
nuclear weapons by Iran will
have huge consequences for
[INAUDIBLE].
But Iran is under no pressure
to do anything.
And if you look at the
negotiating record, and
compare the American position
today from what it was at the
beginning of the negotiation
about 10 years ago, you will
see that with every negotiation,
we have made a
new offer on the theory that
somewhere there is something.
And so in a way, we are
negotiating with ourselves.
So you asked me what
will happen.
Absent some significant
additional pressure on Iran,
Iran will get nuclear weapons.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And then
what happens?
HENRY KISSINGER: And the
addition of pressure now is
much harder to organize than
it would have been.
Because it would have to be the
threat of force by us or
the threat of force by Israel.
And we have moved from--
the original American position
was Iran could not have any
principle and any facilities
to produce fissionable
material, no reprocessing.
We have now moved to agreeing
that there are certain types
of reprocessing and enrichment
they could do, and that the
only thing that's a
red line is the
acquisition of nuclear weapons.
Which if you have enough
fissionable material, it's
relatively easy to do.
So I would say the probability
is that Iran
will get nuclear weapons.
Or, as Netanyahu said last
weekend, that Israel may go to
war to prevent that.
And then we will have--
ERIC SCHMIDT: A real mess.
HENRY KISSINGER:
--quite a mess.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Well, you lived
through '67, '73 wars in the
government and in
the campaign.
In a situation where Iran
actually gets a nuclear
weapon, and Israel is now on a
war footing, the Sunni will
then also get nuclear weapons.
And then we'll have
a nuclearized
Arab-Israeli world.
Is that roughly correct?
HENRY KISSINGER: Yes.
I would think that if Iran
gets nuclear weapons, the
Sunni world will acquire
nuclear weapons.
And then nuclear weapons will
have spread into countries
that are not as technically
able or rich enough to
safeguard them the way they
were safeguarded in the
two-power world.
And when I think back to my
experience, we lived,
essentially, in a two-power
nuclear world.
And people sometimes ask me
what was my biggest worry.
I wasn't in a fret.
I can't say I wasn't worried.
But the day to day activities, I
felt, I was there to handle.
The question I could
never answer for
myself fully was this--
what if we reach a point
where the only
recourse is nuclear weapons?
Would I be prepared to
recommend to the
president to use it?
And the issue was that the
casualties that could be
produced in a matter of hours
was so vast that and would
live in a new world.
And it raised the question of if
anybody had the moral right
to do that.
Luckily, we never got to the
point where I had to give a
final answer.
But probably I wouldn't
have recommended it.
But I'm not arguing that.
But now you have countries that
don't have these systems
and some countries that have a
ideology according to which a
lot of human life makes
you more eligible
for heavenly bliss.
So then I think if they do
spread, generally, nuclear war
will become more likely.
People say, yes, we can
always deter them.
But this isn't like Russia.
Russia had comparable risks as
we did, as between religious
Islam and countries, the
assessment of risk is not
homogeneous.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Your history, of
course, was that you were a
professor at Harvard and worked
on the Richard Nixon
campaign, and when he became
president, became national
security adviser, secretary of
state, and eventually held all
of those jobs.
HENRY KISSINGER: No, I didn't
work on the Nixon campaign.
I worked on the Rockefeller
campaign against Nixon.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: No,
it was strange.
Could never happen today, that
a principle advisor of one
candidate gets invited by the
other candidate to be his
security advisor.
It was very courageous
of Nixon.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So for
those of you who--
I was a teenager at the time.
And when this grand bargain
between Dr. Kissinger and the
president came together, it was
a subject of extraordinary
interest in the press.
And Dr. Kissinger was followed
everywhere, and was seen as
this incredibly powerful role.
And in history, people talk a
lot about the relationship
between yourself and
President Nixon.
I am extremely grateful to you
because I would have been
drafted, sent to Vietnam,
and, in my view, killed.
And because you managed
to settle the
war, I am here today.
And for those of you who are not
my age, which is the vast
majority of you, it's very
difficult to describe what it
feels like to have a draft card
and have your friends
being drafted.
And this really was the reality,
which, of course,
tore the country apart.
What was the nature of the
relationship with you and
President Nixon that allowed
you two together to do
something extraordinary
in China, do something
extraordinary in the Israeli
world, and the Vietnam War.
What was the nature of it?
HENRY KISSINGER: I had never met
Nixon when he asked me to
be his security advisor.
Nixon was personally so insecure
in his personal
relationships that when he asked
me to be his security
adviser, I didn't know
what he wanted.
I knew he wanted something.
But he didn't want
to be rebuffed.
So we had a two-hour
conversation.
And I left knowing he wanted
something, but not knowing
what it was.
A week later, John Mitchell
called me up and said, well,
are you going to take
the job or not?
And I said, what job?
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: And Mitchell
said, oh my God, he screwed
this up again.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: So now
I go to Nixon again.
This time he offers me the
job unambiguously.
And again, this was a different
age, and so you have
to consider a Harvard
professor's arrogance.
I said to Nixon, I've opposed
you for 15 years, and I want
to spend a week asking my
friends, because I don't want
to lose my friends.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: And he should
have said get lost.
He said take a week.
On the second day of that week,
Nelson Rockefeller, who
had been in Venezuela
and unreachable--
different period--
called me--
came back.
And I told him what
had happened.
And he said, has it ever
occurred to you that Nixon is
taking a bigger chance on
you than you on him?
Which was absolutely true.
So I accepted.
So the question is, what
brought us together?
The way the relationship
worked was not--
on a personal basis, we were
not great friends.
We saw each other socially
relatively daily, considering
that we spent many
days together.
But I had studied the making
of peace, the creation of
international order.
I was going to write a series
of books on that subject.
He was [INAUDIBLE], and
therefore he had also done a
lot of reading.
So strangely, unexpectedly, both
of us liked to begin with
the question I put to you
before, which is analyzing
where are we.
What are we to try to do?
And on that basis--
not on the basis of personal
friendship--
we came to a very parallel
conclusions.
And for example, take the
opening to China.
There had been 163 meetings of
American ambassador and the
Chinese ambassador in
Warsaw to discuss
the opening of relations.
And there was a well defined
agenda, which had to do with
Taiwan, claims and assets,
various immunity claims.
It was a long list, and not one
of them had been settled.
So when Nixon sent me to
China, there were no
communications between China
and the United States.
But it was also technically
not possible for me.
I couldn't pick up the phone
and call them and say, it's
going this way.
So we decided--
we hadn't even met
the Chinese yet--
that I would scrap the entire
program, and that I would say
to the Chinese, before we go
back to a program, let's first
try to understand where
each of us is going.
And so if you read the
transcripts of my so-called
secret visit, you will see that
Chou and I talked like
two college professors,
explaining to each other what
our country is trying to do.
On my second visit, before
Nixon got there--
and the way Nixon and I operated
on these things was
we never wanted to be in a
position where everything
depended on Nixon's
conversations
with the other leader.
Because if you get to that point
among heads of state,
there's nothing to
have recourse to.
So I was sent to China a second
time to work out what
later became known as the
Shanghai Communique.
And I arrived with a communique
approved by Nixon
that was a very traditional
communique.
And Chou and I first
accepted it.
Then Mao saw it.
And Mao said, this
is bullshit.
It pretends that we agree
on everything.
And we don't.
So why don't we do something
different.
Why don't we put all our
disagreements into this
communique, and put a few
agreements at the end.
Then the agreements will
be taken seriously.
So I was stuck in Beijing.
I couldn't call Nixon and say,
we've just reversed everything
you've already approved.
But I felt absolutely confident
that he would
approve it.
So I'm saying this not to prove
anything about myself,
but to show what was the nature
of the relationship.
So on the one hand, it was
personally friendly but aloof,
but substantively
very intense.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Today, when you go
to Beijing, there the three
major terminals.
You've been many times since.
And there is the little terminal
where your airplane
landed for the first visit
that you opened up.
Whenever I go by that,
I see that terminal.
And I imagine you in the early
1970s doing that, and a
country full of bicycles
and gray uniforms.
What was Mao like, and what was
the culture like as you
engaged it?
How did it feel when
you landed and when
you spoke with them?
HENRY KISSINGER: Before
we get to this, let
me explain to you--
a few months ago, the Chinese
gave a dinner for me.
And they found everybody who had
ever met me, especially on
the secret trip.
And they all told me the
troubles they went through
preparing the jet for travel.
There had never been a
707 land in China.
So they didn't have a
game plan for it.
And they couldn't order one,
because they didn't want to
put out the word that
a 707 was coming.
So they constructed
one from pictures.
And they weren't sure what would
actually happen, but it
would fit properly.
So then a lady was in charge of
preparing the guest house
where I was going to stay.
And she got it into her head
that Americans like lawns.
But unfortunately, the space in
front of the guest house,
because of the Cultural
Revolution, had been planted
with spinach.
So she had four weeks
to get a lawn down.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: Those were the
problems the Chinese had.
What was Mao like,
was the question.
Also, to give you a flavor of
how these relationships were,
on my first visit, my so-called
secret visit, I was
probably the only visitor to
China who made heroic efforts
to avoid meeting Mao.
And the belief was that with all
the friendship [INAUDIBLE]
between Nixon and me, I knew
he wanted to be the first
American to meet Mao.
And I knew it was a risk to
my relationship with him.
So Mao had given orders, we now
know, he didn't want to
ask for a meeting.
So as soon as I asked for
a meeting, I was to
be brought to him.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
you don't ask.
HENRY KISSINGER: And
I didn't ask.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY KISSINGER: And so my whole
secret visit was spent
talking to Chou Enlai, which
was no hardship.
But what was Mao like?
I met him five times.
And of course, he's responsible
for the killing of
tens of millions of people.
The Mao I met was not
the killer Mao.
It was a acting like
a Chinese saint.
He was extremely intelligent.
He conducted the
conversations.
Almost all leading statesmen
that I've met say, I've got
five points I have to
make to you, and
they make their points.
He wouldn't do that.
He would begin by saying, what
is your consideration of--
give you a topic.
Then you'd say whatever
you said.
And he'd keep that
dialogue going.
So you really engaged in a
Socratic dialogue with him.
I had one meeting that
lasted four hours.
And it lasted four hours because
he had decided to
replace Chou Enlai, which
we didn't know.
But he wanted a Bible in which
he had commented on every
aspect of foreign policy so it
could be used as a reference
statement for the Chinese
bureaucracy after Chou Enlai
disappeared.
And David [INAUDIBLE]
was with me, who had
met de Gaulle.
And he said that was one
of the most astonishing
intellectual performances.
And he would make sarcastic
comments.
He was always polite, but he'd
say such things as, you
Americans remind
me of swallows.
He stopped and turned to the
interpreter and said, should I
have said sparrows?
No, they decided to
say swallows.
of swallows that fly up into
the air when a storm
approaches and flap
your wings.
But you, professor, and I know
that the flapping of the wings
does not affect the coming
of the storm.
So he'd make these comments,
but it would
always get to a point.
So he was a personality that
really dominated any room,
with a really superb
strategic grasp.
Now, he would kill anybody
who got in his way.
That's another side of him.
Which I didn't see.
But we all know about
it, unchallenged.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So after my trip
to North Korea, you and I
spoke a little bit about
North Korea.
What do you think will happen
in the relationship between
China and North Korea?
You told me, at the time, that
the only thing that matters is
China's support for North
Korea at this point.
HENRY KISSINGER: I think--
as a general proposition--
we are now at the point where,
partly because of Chinese
internal necessities, and
partly because its new
leadership has a different life
experience than some of
the previous ones-- new
leadership in China--
that it's a possibility of
recasting the Sino-American
relationship.
And a new Chinese leader has put
it in this question, is it
possible for two countries that
are normally adversaries
to move into a cooperative
relationship?
And he made that
as a challenge.
I believe that he has every
incentive to answer this
constructively because of the
enormous consequences of the
changes that he's thinking
of making.
If that is true, a good test
case will be Korea.
Because that is an issue that
can only be solved between
China the United States
initially.
And I'm beginning think
it may be possible.
And if that happens, some of the
proliferation issues that
I mentioned to you before will
be dramatically changed.
If some country is actually
giving up nuclear weapons
because of the collaboration
of two
major nuclear countries.
And the North Korea you saw
I thought had very little
likelihood.
And I probably said
that to you.
And now I think it's conceivable
to me that it
could happen, say, in
the next two years.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I'd like to move
to some of the Dory questions
that our employees
have submitted.
And as you can imagine, there
are quite a few questions
about a young man who's name
is Edward Snowden, who is
currently in temporary
residence at
the airport in Russia.
One of the questions is, "How
do you feel that Edward
Snowden's current political
limbo will play out?
If you were advising either
the US or Russia on the
situation, what advice would
you offer either the US or
Russia?" And I do know that you
give advice to both the US
and Russia.
There's another question
from an employee.
"Do you still believe, as was
reported around the Pentagon
Papers, that people who leak
government misdeeds should be
prosecuted?
Why shouldn't we prosecute the
officials who committed the
misdeeds first?" What is your
view of Snowden, PRISM, NSA
spying, Russia, the US?
What will happen?
HENRY KISSINGER: My view of--
I find Snowden despicable.
The acquisition by any one
institution of such a monopoly
of information that cannot be
checked by any institutional
process in the hands of a few
people I find worrisome.
And so I am not at ease about
the NSA collection.
But I recognize the problem with
which they were dealing.
And I don't know enough about
it and I don't know enough
technology to know whether it
could have been done in a more
discriminating way.
But if somebody said to me,
should we take another look at
this vast collection?
I would say, yes, we should
take another look at this.
Should one man assume the right
to pass out that level
of information, doing such
enormous damage to our
intelligence capabilities?
Because once the other side
knows what you are capable of
collecting, it will
force you into
another totally new field.
Of course, if somebody's aware
of an individual misdeed, he
may fulfill a moral necessity
to be a whistleblower.
But when somebody arrogates to
himself the right to do such
enormous damage to his society
without any attempt to
understand where it comes from,
I think it's just a form
of, I think, a kind of
self-regard that
I find quite repulsive.
Now, on the Pentagon Papers,
it's not correct that I
advocated the prosecution
of it.
I recommended nothing
in particular.
But the Pentagon Papers raised,
again, the issue.
They were released while I was
preparing the secret trip to
China, in the same months, and
while we were conducting
negotiations with Vietnam
on ending the war.
And I thought that if you dump
out 15,000 papers, it says
something about the ability of
your government to conduct any
meaningful direct secret
negotiation, that the effort
there had to be resisted.
And you also understand this
about the Pentagon Papers.
These were papers collected in
the Johnson Administration
about the leaker's perception of
misdeeds in the Kennedy and
Johnson Administration.
Not one of them touched the
Nixon Administration.
And if one had played it as a
straight political thing, it
would have been possible
for us to say, now
you see what we inherited.
It's a pity they're out,
but you now understand.
We were defending Nixon
and Kennedy papers--
Johnson and Kennedy papers,
not Nixon papers.
But the magnitude of the
Pentagon Papers were
children's game.
Because most of them, it turned
out, were really quite
irrelevant.
Because they were second-level
papers.
They came about because McNamara
had ordered a study
when he was secretary of defense
of what went wrong.
And they were all connected
in one place, and
so they were leaked.
So I can respect people
who leak about
a particular misdeed.
I do not respect people who
endanger the national security
the way Snowden has.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So you and I have
talked some about your
view of democracy and your view
of history and how the
globe is changing.
And I wanted to talk a little
bit about that, a little bit
about leadership, and then I
want to talk a little bit
about your view of Google and
the things Google should do
and should not do
as we conclude.
When I interviewed you for my
book, and thank you very much
for that, you indicated that
true great leaders are
extremely rare.
And I inferred from that that
it's even harder today to
become a great leader--
to be found, to be
elected, to be appointed.
You mentioned in our
conversation that de Gaulle
was one of these great
leaders who
managed to unify a society.
I know you're thinking
about this in
terms of global structure.
What do you think will
happen with the next
generation of leaders?
Are you optimistic, in this new
world, highly connected,
very short-term focused, that
we'll end up with eventually
better leaders?
Worse leaders?
Different leaders?
HENRY KISSINGER: Of course, you
all understand that I come
from a different world.
And I see that when I deal
with my grandchildren.
And I don't deplore this.
But the task of a leader is to
take its society, or his
organization, from where it is
to where it has never been.
And that means, inevitably, that
he will face opposition
from the world as it
is, to some extent.
Now, that, of course, requires
great insight.
But it also requires enormous
moral courage.
Because you have to rely on
your own convictions until
your society has caught
up with you.
Churchill had this quality.
De Gaulle had this quality.
I would argue Franklin Roosevelt
had this quality.
Now, in the modern technological
world, I see a
lot of leaders in the technology
side that would
meet these requirements.
But in the political side, the
world is presented, if you'll
forgive me, by Google through
fragmented excerpts from a
wide range of sources.
There's more information
available than anybody ever
dreamed of.
But how to translate that
information into knowledge
that is relevant to a historical
process and into
wisdom, into the next step,
that cannot be met.
At least, I don't think it has
been met by existing search
engines approach.
When I look at my own life, when
I first started meeting
political leaders, they asked
me what to think.
Then they now ask
me what to say.
It's a different problem.
And now they don't even ask that
anymore, because they go
to search engines to tell them
what the dominant view is.
I read somewhere that Obama
had 48 million card files,
which told him who the friends
of people were.
And I know Romney had 10
million [INAUDIBLE].
But next time, they both
will have 48 million.
And I'm worried about the
future of democracy.
If you don't have debates
about issues that are
generated out of the gut of the
leaders, but where instead
the leaders go to technical
experts to tell them what the
mood is, well, I think that the
requirement of a leader is
to say where you ought to
go, not where you are.
And that's my concern with the
long-term social impact of a
great institution that I
admire, like Google.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So you have
expressed privately some
concerns that Google actually
needs to think about our role,
that because so many people are
using Google, that we're
actually shaping
the discussion.
Can you express what should we
do differently, if anything?
HENRY KISSINGER: As I've said
innumerable times here, I know
I'm from a different world.
I am not attacking this world.
This is the world in which
we're going to live.
I think that my concern about
Google results from its
excellence, not from
its failures.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK,
we'll take that.
HENRY KISSINGER: No, if I could
say you're cooking the
result deliberately--
ERIC SCHMIDT: Which
we are not.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC SCHMIDT: So we're clear.
HENRY KISSINGER: No.
No, if I could say that, then
that's one problem.
That's very relatively
easily fixable.
But when you are the best engine
for producing facts--
but when sometimes the issue
is, in terms of long-range
thinking, not what is a fact
but what's a relevant fact,
then it creates a concern.
I don't know what
you should do.
I talked to you about setting
up an internal system of
checks and balances, which
indicates how much confidence
I have in you.
No, I'm not saying the
government should do this.
But I'm talking about a
50-year perspective.
I'm not talking about the
next year or two.
And I don't know whether
there is an answer.
And this grows out of my respect
for Eric, so that I
occasionally tell him
a concern I have.
This is not something
I'm taking
public or arguing about.
But it's on my mind.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I do think one
of your criticisms is that
we've gone from reading books
to five word sentences, that
there is a change in your
lifetime, which you're very
worried about, about
information.
Is that roughly correct?
HENRY KISSINGER: When I look at,
say, the Lincoln debate,
or the Gladstone-Disraeli
Debate, you had political
leaders who absorbed a lot of
facts, and then presented them
in two hour [INAUDIBLE]
to an interested public so
that they internalize.
When you learn things in
fragments from a search
machine, you don't necessarily
internalize it.
Because look at it and you
absorb it for the moment.
But you don't have to
internalize it because you can
always get the answer again
when you need it.
But some things you ought to
internalize even if you don't
need it at the moment.
But on the other hand, you
make available a range of
information that is so far
superior to anything previous
generations had.
I look at it from the point of
view that when societies run
up against problems that they
cannot solve, that some
demagogue, Caesar, emerges
somewhere along the line.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I'm sorry--
meaning that the person just
sort of captures the
conversation as a demagogue?
HENRY KISSINGER: Captures the
conversation as a demagogue.
And when 250 million card files
are debating each other,
or printouts, or whatever
you call them--
ERIC SCHMIDT: In our case,
it's called big data.
HENRY KISSINGER: That's what
worries me, the fact that
there are a lot of things that
worry me in the world that I
can't do anything about.
And I didn't think we would take
the conversation public,
but that is my view.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But one answer to
your question, which is why
I wanted to ask you directly,
would be if Google could
invent technology that could
take the information that's
currently arranged and construct
something of the
quality of a Lincoln debate,
or an Israeli debate.
If that worked, that would
be a big improvement?
HENRY KISSINGER: Yes.
Or some way to get different
interpretations that people
can reflect about as they're
forming their own opinions.
Because in the political world,
you finally meet people
who are willing to stand up
against what seems to be the
conventional wisdom
from time to time.
ERIC SCHMIDT: One of the things
that Google is in fact
working on is the ability to
more deeply understand subject
area, that information.
And there are research projects
inside the company,
some people here in the room,
who are in fact trying to
solve the problem that
you laid out.
And I'm really glad that you
were able to come to state it
as clearly as possible.
We've reached the
end of our time.
I wanted to tell you
all that, for me,
great strategy matters.
When I look at politics--
I spend a lot of time in
these worlds now--
the greatest strategies start
from a principle of, what are
we trying to accomplish?
and figuring out a
way to get there.
The man to my right has had
a series of extraordinary
strategies.
And I wanted you to hear how he
approached them, and how he
actually dealt with the
reality of the time.
And I would say that the world
is a far, far better place
because of the opening up of
the world that I think you
properly deserve
the credit for.
It is a great honor
to have you here
at Google, Dr. Kissinger.
Thank you very much.
HENRY KISSINGER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]